- War die Party gut?
- Sehr gut! Die Party war super!
- International, oder?
Marc kommt aus Frankreich,
Sascha aus Russland und Selma aus Syrien.
- Selma … ist sie … refugee?
- Ja, sie ist ein Flüchtling.
- Flüchtling.
- Darf Selma in Deutschland bleiben?
- Keine Ahnung.
Sie hat noch keine Aufenthaltserlaubnis.
- Sie spricht sehr gut Deutsch!
- Stimmt. Sie macht einen Deutschkurs
und lernt sehr schnell.
Und welche Sprachen sprichst du, Nico?
- Englisch … Naja ... ein bisschen.
- Und Spanisch und ein bisschen Deutsch.
- Ja, ich spreche Spanisch, ein bisschen
Englisch und ein bisschen Deutsch.
Welche Sprachen sprichst du?
- Ich spreche Deutsch, Englisch und
Italienisch, aber sehr schlecht.
- Woher kommst du?
Welche Sprachen sprichst du?
- Ich komme aus Thailand.
Ich spreche Thai, Chinesisch, Englisch,
Deutsch, Französisch und Italienisch.
- Wow.
- Freunde!
So, kommt mal schnell her!
Das Foto von deiner Tante Yara.
Es gibt eine Antwort und eine Adresse.